e aí
e no primeiro trimestre 2018 que estava
a procura de estágio profissional e
produção de crédito a faculdade vocês
gostaram servia também como uma cadeira
na faculdade mesmo texto demitido cerca
de dez cartas e quase nenhuma delas foi
respondida até que uma das minhas
colegas apresentam a senhora a diana se
ela que a fundadora de uma organização e
designer de produtos de cuidados
femininos
e no meio da conversa ela disse para mim
esse vídeo eu não posso colocar a
trabalhar comigo não tenho mais porque
diana eu preciso de trabalho quis de
estágio terminar o meu o meu perigo ela
disse não porque que não estou falando
de assuntos de mulheres bom eu tentei
convencer ela não porque eu já fiz outro
estágio na área de gestão de idades não
sei que por favor ela disse não não pode
ah pois é convence ela e deu uma semana
ficou a pensar por ela ligou para mim
vamos voltar a conversar foi quando ela
disse para mim tu vai ter que falar
sobre menstruação para homens
o qual eu fiquei tipo ok como é que a
dizer agora
tá bom eu usava mim do estágio então eu
aceitei só que ela pois disse para mim
olha o está esperar e minerado e o buzz
gente será tá aí eu tive a certeza que
eu queria aceitei a
e não se abusava de dinheiro também
importante
bom e depois tivemos uma formação e
acreditem eu era um total que esse
jovens eu era único e um homem o único
rapaz desde a faculdade também serve
estive no meio e seria do meio do grupo
de mulheres eram quatro eram três
meninas eu era o único rapaz começamos a
trabalhar em algumas é uma escola de zag
maputo foi daí onde eu descobrir o que
que eu queria ser o quê que eu queria
fazer profissionalmente eu descobri que
eu era um homem feminista eu descobri
que queria trabalhar na área de gênero
eu descobri que queria abraçar causas de
interesse de mulheres
e eu não procuro que as muito que os
homens e as mulheres sejam iguais eu
procuro que as mulheres e os homens
tenham direitos iguais
tá certo
e eu trabalhando no projeto eu vou
envolvendo cerca de três mil nas
barrigas e mesmo rapazes a minha
responsabilidade como já havia dito era
só de trabalhar com homens ou com
rapazes e o projeto tinha um
questionário e também palestras para
medir o livro dos mesmos adolescentes e
perceber como esse vídeo com buscas
relacionadas a menstruação
e foi no meio desse projeto que eu
percebi que a menstruação é motivo de
medo é motivo de vergonha é motivo de
segregação é motivo de preocupação é
motivo de medo para as raparigas em
particular
e isso pode afetar negativamente no seu
dia a dia assim como o seu
aproveitamento escolar
e eu vou partilhar um bocadinho a minha
experiência tendo em conta os dados e
informação que nós precisamos local
e para mim existem quatro fatores que
contribuem negativamente para misturar o
que coloca a menstruação como um
problema a família as práticas e crenças
culturais a falta de informação e a
escola
é de que forma a família contribui
negativamente
nós já sabemos dani tem mal que a
educação parte de casa tem certeza aqui
parte de nós sabe que nós sabemos hoje
em dia é porque nós aprendemos em casa e
o que acontece na prática é que as
famílias com as mães em particular pouco
conversam com seus filhos sobre esse
assunto deixamos como papel da escola o
que elas abriram por si só
é bom no nosso estudo foi possível
perceber que pelo menos setenta e dois
por cento das raparigas que participaram
do nosso estudo nunca tiver não tinham
nenhum conhecimento sobre menstruação
aquando do seu primeiro período e isso
teve implicações negativas porque elas
não souberam gerir de forma confortável
e segura o seu período ou seus períodos
o 25 porcento as raparigas não podiam
andar perto de alguns membros ou não
pode andar perder alguns membros da
família vocês estamos assumir onde a
rapariga tem que ter conforto informação
e segurança já problemas imagine quando
ela estiver fora quando ele estiver na
sociedade como é que ela vai se sentir
tô falando das crenças e práticas
culturais eu vou focar naquilo que
costuma-se dizer que as mulheres
raparigas não deve ou não pode fazer
é uma rapariga menstruada não pode
salgar a comida ou não pode cozinhar
o outro uma mulher menstruada não pode é
entrar ou pagar o mesmo espaços direto
mais nas questões religiosas porque ela
está impura
e outra coisa é que uma uma mulher
menstruada não pode transar a outra
porque senão cai nos cabelos
é uma coisa que eu vi também como os
meus rapazes é que ele disse para mim
olha dizem que uma uma mulher menstruada
não pode tocar na cabeça de um bebê
porque senão caem os cabelos então fico
a pensar todos aqui seríamos caves e as
mulheres seriam todas peruca né
e com outro fato é que acredita-se que
uma rapariga quando começa a menstruar
ela já está pronta para conseguir e isso
tem implicações negativas não consegue
me a casamentos prematuros
consequentemente ela vai ter que
desistir da escola vai ter que abandonar
a escola
a falta de informação vou tocar muito
nos homens
e são eles que criam problemas também
é né
é sim
[Música]
um copo desculpa que o que se queres
homens aqui sabe exatamente quando é que
a sua mulher ver o período
e consegue seguir isso né ok ok tudo bem
não vamos não vamos sensibilidade nós
vamos querer ser feliz sensibilidade
um dos meus rapazes que eu trabalhei com
eles
há pelo menos trinta por cento afirmaram
que nunca ouviram falar sobre a
menstruação e para eles não é normal um
homem conversar brincar interagir com
uma mulher enquanto ela estiver
menstruada e assumiram também que já
provocaram já assistiram provocações já
lançaram piadas para ir a paris
e como é que uma como é que elas
estendem também como era raparigas vão
se sentir esse nesse nessa situação
algumas raparigas no que concerne
realmente a falta de informação
assumiram que não se sentem confortáveis
em falar sobre esses assuntos tanto em
casa tanto na escola assim como na
sociedade
a escola já vendido
e a menstruação ou cinco misturada esse
podem diferir no aproveitamento escolar
no campo nós podemos constatar que
algumas raparigas não maior parte delas
costumam faltar à escola costumam ter
problemas de concentração nas aulas
é e quais são os fatores estão por
detrás disso primeiro espaços
confortáveis seguros e higiênicos para a
rapariga poder gerir o seu período de
forma confortável quanto quantos agir
estamos a perceber trocar tenso lavar as
malditas entre também acho que as
mulheres entendem melhor eu também tenho
a né e
e o que acontece uma rapariga sai de
casa chega na escola para algumas
escolas as casas de banho são
partilhadas rapazes e raparigas
partilham a mesma casa de banho
é sim é um fato se não partilho a casa
de banho permanece a maior parte do
tempo fechada
e se não está fechada e não é partilhada
é porque não tem condições higiênicas tá
toda emendada de água ou não tem água
sair e como é que uma rapariga vai se
sentir aí eu não posso ir à escola hoje
porque já sempre buscar lá e a porta tá
trancada ou fechada e ou porque eu tenho
que partilhar a casa de banho com alguém
não sei que outra grande preocupação das
raparigas acho que toda mulher é sujei
sujei elas não consegue se concentrar
nas aulas porque elas não tem algumas
não tem uns penso convencionais falo
daqui as pessos não sei algumas usam
trapos de roupas né para poder colocar e
dar andamento a sua vida tenho contar
com as provocações dos rapazes e
e eles não entendem por exemplo quando
uma colega também isolada tá meio triste
o que é que se passa são piadas talvez
seja a famosa tpm tensão pré-menstrual a
gente não sabe é
é né
e esse é um grande problema que nós
temos nessa cidade
olá eu sou queria deixar eu quero deixar
aqui um apelo
nós temos aqui mais pais encarregados de
educação e representantes de
instituições governamentais e
não-governamentais vamos tornar a
menstruação o ciclo menstrual e um
assunto normal falado em todos os cantos
em todos em todos os lugares temos que
conversar com os nossos irmãos tem que
conversar com os meus filhos não vamos
esperar a não vamos deixar ela completar
10 tá não próximo álbum será falar com
ela e de repente ação ela já começou a
menstruação porque eu acho que eu
acredito que para quem está a começar a
menstruação não avisa que amanhã eu vou
começar a disse para ela para as suas já
tem experiência já sabe to com cólica eu
tô com dor e que tô com dor não sei onde
é porque vai descer a menstruação mas
como a rapariga que não atende uma
experiência é uma coisa complicada não
e vamos tornar esse assunto uma coisa
como falada e conquistada normalmente em
todo estado um apelo também a melhoria
de condições nas nossas escolas
e para não afetar as nossas raparigas
obrigado
e aí